hey guys I'm Philip Alena and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 6
episode 8 no one
and so we're wrapping up the season
there's only two episodes left we're
about to head into episode 9 which is
always epic Ned's beheading battle the
Blackwater the red wedding the wildling
attack on the wall Shireen getting
burned
drogon save Daenerys all happen episode
9 and next week it's the epic battle of
the bastards finally Snowbowl that
episode is so big actually that I've
already started my analysis of it and I
cannot wait to share that with you but
this week / tradition the show gave us
in episode 8 that stretches out that
tension as much as possible before the
explosive climax that we're gonna get
next week
I like that game where you keep adding
rubber bands to a watermelon until it
explodes which is exactly what happened
in episode 8 two seasons ago we have so
many things to point out this episode I
just got to get into it let's start with
the opening images and we technically
opened on an image of darkness followed
by the aftermath of the murder of
someone Arya hates which perfectly
mirrors what happens later with the
darkness and the aftermath of the death
of the wave but as for the opening scene
itself you probably noticed that lady
crane took Arya's advice and she rewrote
this monologue she hated before you my
friend Oh cruel gods take my life
instead break and I'll face another day
when my sweet boys dead but now I seek
vengeance on sunset of [ __ ]
and my brother the IMP now here's what's
fun about that in our breakdown of
episode 6 we talked about how the advice
that Arya gave lady crane to ignore her
orders and rewrite her own story
changing her character's journey that
was actually Arya advising herself to do
the same but rather than the show
leaving it there by having lady crane
actually taking the advice to the two
characters continue to run parallel
there's a bit more to these parallels
but I'll mention them a little bit later
there's another interesting tidbit here
the new monologue that Flo Cersei gives
is actually foreshadowing the real
Circe's inner monologue later in the
episode my son my child king fight nomu
you can see real Circe's grief over
losing her son her child king and then
you also see the same turn when she too
decides to seek vengeance over those who
took her from him but now I
- vengeance Sansa and Tyrion in the play
but the Tourelles in the high Sparrow in
real life as that part of the scene
comes to an end you film buffs might
have recognized this tracking shot
following lady crane backstage it's a
very specific choice made by the
director most likely a reference to
Darren Aronofsky's signature move used
in the movies Black Swan and the
wrestler these movies and this scene are
about performers who put on a false
identity when they're onstage but that's
what defines them once they leave the
stage they remained turned away from us
to illustrate that when not performing
they become faceless people they are no
one obviously it's a title this episode
so it does come into play actually
pretty often
up next we see lady crane discover aria
and it's here that we realize pretty
much all of those theories that
everybody was wondering about regarding
arias stabbing were not true and I'm
gonna point out that before we even told
you about them I was like yeah this
probably is not gonna be true but I
wouldn't have been cool if it was I will
say if you're still looking for some
hope that there was more going on in
that attack the director of this episode
did stay well he doesn't think there was
he made sure to also point out he
doesn't technically know for sure it's
only what he thinks the writers and the
show creators could have intended
something else so it's a tiniest sliver
of hope if you need some later when lady
crane tells Aria that she should be an
actress this is when the parallels in
these two characters begin to diverge
Aria says I do you think it could
remember with the lines which makes
sense since aria recently suggested lady
crane changed the lines to a play
clearly not really respecting a script
but it's actually referring to arias
inability to follow orders she just
can't
instead she always just improvises her
own path and so despite the fact that
book aria actually does take up this
offer and goes on to play the role of
Sansa in the play show Aria declined
being an actress here and remember that
acting is just a fill in for the idea of
being a faceless man which is the main
job that aria has now decided not to do
but it's not until the end of the
episode that she chooses who she wants
to actually be instead a girl is always
talk of Winterfell side note this line
was super meta because obviously Maisie
Williams the actress has no problem
remembering lines except ironically
according to the actress when somebody
recommended to her that she should try
out acting she said the exact
same thing are you dead that she
wouldn't be able to remember the lines
also did he catch the Sansa actress his
name its Bianca one of the few times in
Game of Thrones that they've picked a
pretty normal name from our world and
that's because it's probably a reference
to the Bianca's in the plays of William
Shakespeare in slo Bianca's a super
jealous girl and later she's accused of
murdering the object of her jealousy and
in the other it's Bianca in Taming of
the Shrew and she's ready to step out
into the spotlight but she's
specifically being blocked by her older
sassy but brilliant sister so they both
feel pretty familiar own did you catch
the other parallel between Lady crane
and Aria how did lady crane deal with
the girl that wanted her dead she robbed
her of her pretty face great minds think
alike now before we move on I just want
to point out this kind of interesting
thing that uh Aria said about what she
might do now she wants to go west of
Westeros because no one knows what's out
there apparently people think it's the
edge of the world and that's a reference
to our own history when we were getting
close to the end of the Middle Ages
people decided to try to prove there was
more to the world you just had to go
further west and just as Westeros and
Essos represented Europe and Asia it's
possible that artists journey
potentially one that would maybe take
place after the show's over could have
her discovering the Westeros equivalent
of America it would be a good connection
to her direwolf's namesake Nymeria which
by the way if you're new here I think
that all direwolf names predict the
owners story and Nymeria was actually
famous for establishing a new colony
that is what Dorne turned out to be so
yeah maybe Ari's gonna establish a new
american-style colony um let's move on
we've got this scene with this poor
bastard who twice in a row does not see
what is about to hit him once it's a
finger in his butt and then pizza
freakin axe and both are so embarrassing
for him the out-of-focus killer in the
background feels a lot like a shot from
a horror movie like that's Jason or
something weird in that recent movie
actually it follows and the director
uses it because he knows that it builds
tension like crazy and he actually uses
it again with the wave later oh and that
guy that got his butt penetrated that's
fellow youtubers Steve love he's famous
for doing Game of Thrones impressions I
felt for sure that I was dead so it's
pretty cool that now he can technically
start doing an impression of his own
character though they probably wouldn't
let him post it on
when you jam it right up a bunghole boy
jus later we get this scene with Varys
and Tyrion and we find out Varys is
leaving town on some secret mission and
first of all if you're wondering where
he's going well in the books he's got
one thing really interesting left to do
in King's Landing which I'm not gonna
spoil but also I have a feeling he's
actually not going back there he said he
needs to gain more support for Daenerys
we need friends in Westeros and so who
and Westeros could possibly support
putting a Targaryen in command over a
Lannister
boom Dorne that is my guess at least we
haven't seen a lawyer or the sand snakes
since the first episode of the season
but I definitely think we're gonna see
them before the season's over it could
be in a scene where various tries to
recruit them oh and the second thing I
wanted to say about beerus leaving is it
just a coincidence that he leaves
moments before Daenerys gets back but he
also previously arrived moments after
Daenerys left is he avoiding her because
he's scared of her or something again it
could be a coincidence but he also
narrowly avoids the attack from the
slavers I don't know if I believe this
idea that bears could be the harpy
trying to use the sons of harpy to make
Daenerys leave marine earlier and take
Westeros already but I definitely got to
put this into the suspicious column
moving on we get this scene with Cersei
and qui burn and there was this really
big moment when Cersei asked who told
the faith militant that they could come
into her area the Red Keep and cry burn
just stays quiet a bunch of people
interpreted this moment pretty
differently but my guess is that it's
some version of the high Sparrow having
authority these days that he never had
before because of this Union he has two
atomic it's either he gave the
permission himself or he just really
easily like manipulated the crown into
permitting them in but actually whatever
who cares because they're there and
these idiots do not realize what is
waiting there for them
remember that mountain viper fight from
episode 8 two years ago so it's fitting
that episode eight this year has the
mountain ripping off a guy's head but
like for like from the front okay it's
very terrifying but it's also kind of
impressive to do it in that direction
this image definitely leaves Cersei
feeling content but she doesn't realize
actually that this moment her choosing
violence here it's actually yet another
example of her bringing about her own
downfall because it's actually not very
well known just what exactly is going on
with the mountain people no sir
has this guy but as far as they know
he's a mentally-challenged rotting
corpse he hasn't attacked anyone out in
the open yet just secretly but this show
of force here the fact that Cersei has
an unstoppable Franken mountain that's
what Lance L can go report back to the
high Sparrow probably while washing poop
out of his tunic because he looked
terrified he is lucky that it was
already brown but had she shown some
restraint and just had the conversation
with his pharaoh they may not have known
that he's this freakin monster and maybe
this barrel would have had Tommen banned
trials by combat also quick thing to
point out before we move on the shot of
the blood going down the drain into the
sewers of King's Landing I think it's
just a reminder that there are these
full like tunnels beneath the city that
are easily forgotten about we'll come
back to why that's important later
okay so let's skip ahead to bran joking
with pod about whether or not Jaime and
Brienne are banging you I know it comes
off as just like a simple jokey scene
maybe to lighten the tension but
actually there's some pretty clever
storytelling at play here because the
very next scene is between Jaime and
Brienne and it's this very technical
scene about the logistics of a siege the
facts of their situation they talk
strategy and politics if you imagine it
between Jamie and some random Knight
you'll see what I mean it's very
straightforward I'm sent here to reclaim
Riverrun currently defended by the Tully
rebels so you can see the Columbia the
Tully's are rebels because they're
fighting for their home Riverrun was
granted to the phrase by royalty free
but because they gave us this bran scene
right before this moment he tells us
that he thinks these two want to bang it
gives this scene a whole lot of sexual
attention and it adds this subtext to
everything they're saying honor compels
me to fight for sons as kin of course it
does
to fight you
let's hope it doesn't come to that
every time there's a pause you feel like
they're gonna like tear each others
clothes off or bran is just gonna come
in and be like yeah yeah
you guys gonna huh ah anyway it's for
that reason that filter that bran gave
us that I think what is really happening
here when Brehon tries to give earth
keeper back to Jamie it's not about the
sword for him it's about his heart
listen again with that in mind get yours
there will always be humans aside from
the rekindling of a romance here this
scene is about the two things that pull
at Jamie Lannister the angel and the
devil on his shoulders his angel Brian
talks to him like he's Darth Vader and
she's Luke Skywalker telling him he's
still got some honor and I know there is
good in you your knight - so Jamie I
know there's uh nothing you mean while
on the other shoulder is the devil by
way of Tywin Lannister or maybe the evil
emperor if we're gonna keep mixing
metaphors but I I know he's not
literally there in that room but these
tents with their fancy furniture out on
the battlefield the way Jamie's dressed
it's like Tywin's ghost is in this room
actually you could interpret that empty
armor as Tywin's ghost right there it's
exactly like his each time Jamie Dawn's
those he's choosing to step into that
Tywin role and Tywin always wanted Jamie
to be a Lannister not a white knight
Tywin would want him to win by any means
necessary remember the red wedding was
his idea
but it's actually Brean who suggested
Jaime to take the castle without any
bloodshed and that is what he tries to
do so clearly he wants to listen to the
angel and be the good guy but I think
when he hears that the blackfish has
been killed he knows he's failed to do
what she wanted and that's why he waved
goodbye to her so sadly because he's
resigned he's not just waving goodbye to
this woman that he probably loves but
he's resigned to just his own honor and
ability that she represents is also
leaving he just can't seem to be the
good guy we'll talk more later about the
man that Jaime wants to be versus the
cows jerks that he's choosing to play
right now but you can see a hint of this
when he talks about how girls like Sansa
don't live very long Brienne hears it as
kind of like what a dick thing to say
and she gives her retort I don't think
he named when it goes like huh but deep
down Jamie probably was just thinking of
his own daughter Marcella
who's a lot like what's on Sally's used
to be like the precious princess type he
really meant it nice girls don't get to
survive in this world now moving on to
Brienne trying to talk to blackfish into
joining Sansa and John if you're
wondering what this letter says we were
only able to slightly enhance this one
book basically it seems as if the top
part is just establishing who was
sending the letter Lady Sansa of
Winterfell maybe Lady of the North or
something but the second part is her
quickly recapping her story and then
appealing to him as family talking about
her mom his sister and asking for his
help to avenge their family she keeps
bringing up family and that's a smart
move actually
Sansa knows that the Tully words are
family duty honor and family is supposed
to come first in that list a lot of
people try to use those words against
the Tully men throughout the episode and
I'll point them out as they come
anyway brilliant sass doesn't even work
and we're second Kings Landing this is
that moment when Kevin and Tommen kind
of backhand Cersei but touching on our
themes again note that Cersei expects
that she gets to sit in the VIP area for
Royals and Kevin banishes her to stand
with the women of the gallery to Cersei
this is like the utmost insult because
he just effectively stripped her of her
titles her royal tea her identity and
now it's as if she's just another
anonymous face in the crowd she's become
no one sir she then finds out that trial
by combat is off the table and like I
said earlier that's clearly the work of
the high Sparrow and you can tell that
Tommen is actually really struggling
with this it's rare that we even see him
sitting on the throne and that combined
with this decree which he knows is going
to ruin his mother has him very nervous
check out that fidgeting hand but he
shouldn't feel so bad it's all scripts
EES fault really
not just this trial by combat thing but
the situation that she's in remember
she's the one that put the faith into a
higher state of power in King's Landing
this line that Tommen says the faith and
the crown are the two pillars that hold
up this world he's not just quoting the
high Sparrow the high Sparrow who
actually said that when he was quoting
Cersei the face in the crown of the to
pin is this world she's the one that
said that and so when she hears it now
she just feels that sting of her own
scheming working
against her to other irony's to point
out here's one this backstabbing that
Circe's feeling from a Lannister uh
which stings so much harder if she could
hear the score that's playing right now
it's the rains of castamere the song
that plays when Lannisters have beaten
someone often using some sort of
trickery the other irony is that Tommen
has just banned trial by combat because
it's a corrupt way to avoid justice but
on this show the only two times we've
seen an accused person choose trial by
combat it was by Tyrion who was innocent
both times and was being judged by
corrupt courts both times so get your
facts straight Dahman also interesting
that in the episode where Tommen bands
trial by combat we actually see almost
no combat the Riverrun siege is
essentially bloodless and the two big
fights you expect to see this episode
Arya versus the wave and the takedown of
the blackfish they both happen
off-screen and then in terms of general
violence you can't even really call what
the Clegane brothers did battles because
they didn't even end up like breathing
hard during what they did the mountain
actually might not breathe at all
actually but it's like Tommen banned all
combat this episode it's a good thing uh
pisode 9 is right around the corner and
did you catch that Circe's trial is
gonna take place during the festival of
the mother there's a chance that Tommen
thought that was a good date because the
mother is known for her mercy but he
probably didn't catch that that's just
one more thing to rub in Circe's face
you just put your mother on trial during
the festival of the mother that's like
having your mom arrested on Mother's Day
maybe pick a different day now that I
know why your mom is being arrested if
it's serious maybe it should be that
there anyway so what options does Cersei
have now well here's something she's
being charged with all sorts of things
and fornication is one of them but she
isn't specifically being charged with
incest with Jaime but if she decided to
go ahead and admit to that well that
would call Tommen kingship into question
and it would probably result in him
losing the crown that's very intense and
it would totally shake things up since
the faith actually need Tommen to be in
power for them to have power now if you
think that's too crazy oh you probably
aren't familiar with Circe's other
option and that's that rumor that Choir
burn is talking to Cersei about just
your moves
ha let's go ahead and activate theory
time feel free to skip it this time if
you don't want to know what we think
will happen but we don't know if it's
gonna happen alright ready here goes
so you've heard this from us for a while
now that we think Circe is going to set
fire to some or all of King's Landing to
try to take out some enemies or maybe
everyone but let's just add some new
points to this theory one if you're
thinking that Circe wouldn't risk
hurting her son remember that I think
she believes she's already lost him both
to the faith and to the prophecy that
says he's gonna die and if you remember
the last time Circe felt cornered like
this she was about to give Tommen poison
so she's not past killing her own child
so I'd known cuz you're wondering yes
that's a different actor playing Tom and
then I guess they had to hate him up
when he took over Ice King - a lot of
people forget that it was actually
Cersei who ordered the pyromancers to
make all that wildfire in those green
pod we have been working tirelessly day
and night ever since your royal sister
commanded us to do sim it wasn't tyrion
tyrion just orders them to keep making
it for him now but Cersei had already
been planning to not just use it against
the ships like Tyrion did but she was
gonna use it against the men themselves
on land which even bran-new was just way
too dangerous and could burn the whole
city down I remember reading an old
sailors proverb piss on wildfire and
your [ __ ] burns off oh if you pee on it
your penis catches on fire that's too
dangerous Cersei also there's more
precedent because in the books
Cersei burned down the Tower of the hand
using wildfire just because you hated
looking at it after Tywin was killed
there for you remember that pyro montage
we had of Cersei last episode Oh
now go ahead and tack on this new Jaime
lying about Cersei and burning stuff so
it's wool then she seized to banish free
their worst enemies but the reason why
we think the rumor is about the Wildfire
it's been unclear how much there was and
how much got used at the Battle of the
Blackwater and it's also unclear if the
Mad King really had a bunch put under
different parts of the city into tunnels
including right under the great Sept of
Baelor the
with faith but now we're reminded that
the tunnels exist and I just remembered
that Clyburn started hearing little
tidbits about the possibility that the
Mad King was gonna burn the whole city
down a long time ago Jamie first hinted
at it way back in season 3 how many
lines of his safe off a million the
population of King's Landing these
rumors have been building up for a long
time and then here's a new addition to
this theory if Cersei is gonna try to
burn her enemies and potentially all of
King's Landing with them will it be up
to Jamie to stop her killing her like he
did the Mad King he's done the exact
same thing before and he is searching
for honor I know you might think that
Jamie would never kill Cersei but I will
remind you when Jamie told Bryan about
the Mad King way back when and that
delicious hot tub he asked Brienne what
she would have done if she knew that
Renly was gonna burn an entire city Oh
precious bendy commanded you to kill
your own father and stand by one
thousands of men women and children
panting life but you've done it Jamie is
suggesting that even if he was in love
with a ruler like Brian was with Renly
he still probably would have had to have
saved everyone so I think that means he
would kill Cersei what do you think do
you think you would do it personally I
wonder if he'd somehow end up dying with
her maybe but here's the bigger reason
why Jamie might kill Cersei the prophecy
about Circe's children dying in the
books it also has more to it it says
that Cersei will die being choked by the
valonqar that's the high Valyrian word
for little brother it used to seem like
that would be Tyrion who clearly hates
Cersei and loves choking and while
technically the prophecy could apply to
any little brother in the world
it would be pretty poetic if it were her
twin brother her little brother just
because he was born a few moments after
her so now what do you think it's
interesting right all right let's jump
out of theory time okay now before we
get into the totally crazy stuff that's
coming and admissible details for the
rest of the episode I want to use this
moment to fill you in on a little
tradition I have in my house where every
week I rearrange my Game of Thrones
house sigil magnets that I got from loot
crate into the latest Power Rankings and
I've been doing this for the last two
seasons and you would be surprised how
often this shifts and I think we should
start doing these in these recaps so
after last
let's see okay so Aria was dying and
John and Sansa were denied by the
Glovers and meanwhile Daenerys had her
badass speech moment recently so she's
on top then the Starks and then yeah the
Lannisters had a setback but it wasn't
so bad they're basically fine meanwhile
Durr setback is Tommen Baratheon being
totally brainwashed by the high Sparrow
so in terms of power in a way has none
he's completely under someone else's
thumb so that's where I had it last week
but this week
technically Tommen Baratheon shows that
he has more power than the Lannisters so
sorry though I I do know that the faiths
are really the ones behind it but I
don't have a faith magnet uh so whatever
and the Lannisters they've been like
super depressed this episode we'll get
to Tyrion but he all them are very
depressed this episode so they actually
shift to the bottom spot then Daenerys
is barely in this episode but when she
shows up she's kind of dumbfounded and
her cities under attack
so yeah we're gonna slide that Targaryen
heat down to number two and then like
I've been predicting all season the
Starks are coming out on top with arias
antics and her badass name declaration
at the end putting them to the number
one spot now we got start Targaryen
Baratheon Lannister they're not often on
bottom but they definitely are at the
end of this episode oh and at the end of
the video we're gonna do a giveaway and
you're gonna get these same magnets if
you want plus I'm also gonna send you my
own personal loot crate exclusive tart
direwolf USB flash drive I'm gonna load
it with a bunch of surprise stuff I'm
gonna pick it myself
I'm also gonna put a bonus video in
there made by me Eric and Kyle oh and
it's gonna be just made just for you
whoever wins that and we're actually
giving away other things too but I'll
tell you about that more at the end are
the reason that we are getting to do all
this so is because our friends at loot
crate are sponsoring this week's
breakdown a game of Thrones and they are
totally hooking us up I've actually been
subscribed to loot crate for years on my
huge fan but if you've never heard of it
it's amazing it's this monthly
subscription box service where they send
you these geeky or gamer general pop
culture things and it's always around
some sort of theme but it's the exact
kind of stuff that we love on this
channel Marvel Star Wars Walking Dead
etc so like these things
part of a game of Thrones box that I got
last year they had other game to us up
in it too and it's funny because if you
could see the office from where I am
standing you would see that the room is
literally filled with the cool stuff we
get from loot crate and it's all kinds
of stuff like here's Batman right uh
this book is from loot crate this
Terminator skulls from loot crate my
Rick and Morty puzzle that I haven't
done yet
oh that poster is from Luke a oh yeah a
bunch of badass pop figurines from them
that's the joy of it every month you get
something like six to eight items it's
all cool nerd stuff and the box actually
costs less than $20 but the stuff inside
is always worth more than $40 so
obviously a good deal but also because
loot crate is being incredibly nice to
us I hope you use our link
it's lucre comm slash rock stars and our
code which is also rock stars they'll
take 10% off the boxes oh they also said
to tell you that if you want to get in
on the June box which has the theme of
dystopia which I love because I'm super
into stuff after the apocalypse then you
have to sign up by the 19th - 19 - 9
p.m. Pacific time oh you can still get
the percentage off after that day but
you'll miss out on the cool dystopian
boss which I'm excited about and you
have to get the next one
anyway uh stick around for the end of
the video where I'll talk about the
giveaway and tell you the other cool
stuff that we're giving away uh but in
general if you like nerdy stuff sign up
using our link and also say thanks to
loot crate if you happen to see them
somewhere they are very famous for
helping out the little guys on YouTube
even from the very beginning of their
company I've always been aware of them
I've been signed up for a long time and
since they were nice enough to help us
make today's video then if you're
supporting them you really are pretty
directly supporting us so so thank you
in advance but let's keep going we jump
over to marine we're tearing hosts this
really awkward party with Masson day and
grey worm and did you catch this sad
moment for Tyrion by the way when he
describes his dream of drinking wine
with all his closest friends that face
he makes his cuz Taran realizes he has
no friends it's such a terrible thing to
realize but especially considering Varys
just left
he really is left with no one no family
or friends considering how this big
piece feel that he's supposedly made
falls apart in just a few moments you
can see what I meant about Tyrion being
just as depressed as his siblings are
this episode and why the Lannisters had
to go down in the Power Rankings Owen
speaking of how things go for Tyrians
plan there was this little weird word
riddled Etta what's going on with the
episode description and what happens in
this scene HBO said Tyrians plans bear
fruit and often they try to be kind of
clever with their wording so wine is
often referred to as fermented fruit
which is what Tyrion is trying to
explain to grey worm but grey worm
thinks of it as fruit that's probably
turned like it's gone bad it's wrong
tastes like it just turned yes yes
fermentation so while Tyrion thinks his
plans are going perfectly bearing fruit
and that rotting is actually just
fermentation
it's tasty wine now we're worm actually
sees the plans for what they are they're
broadened fruit and he's right the
slavers didn't fall for Tyrians lies and
now they're attacking the slave is
almost working from you you're talking
gave us this now even though I was
pretty hopeful for Tyrion in this
situation I got to remind you that we
pointed out a few episodes ago the calls
told Daenerys that the slavers knew that
they had her captain so that meant that
when Tyrion told some story about
Daenerys just being away the slavers
already knew he was lying and even worse
when they saw there was just Tyrion who
to them is just some random imp and two
slaves that seem to be running marine
like this entire city they knew to go
back to their cities and get their ships
because now is the perfect time to
attack so unfortunately it all kind of
backfired on him that's all a downer
though so Hut's such on the comedy of
this scene and this episode actually
really quick this episode actually had a
lot more jokes and practical jokes than
they usually do that'll mean like funny
lines I mean the characters on the show
we're trying to break the tension in
their world with a joke in each case the
comedy is actually telling us about the
joke tellers themselves the Brotherhood
guys pull the butthole joke because
they're a bunch of depraved buttholes
brawn joke attacks pod reminding us that
he's a dirty fighter and a trickster
Kevan Lannister makes this sarcastic
joke to show Cersei just how little
respect he has for her demand has to be
a
royal announcement I wasn't informed
there is to be a royal announcement in
the throne room at this very moment Oh
miss Sunday's joke is about translators
and the fact that when it comes down to
a life-or-death situation yeah she fears
that her skill set actually isn't that
useful do you know how to swim no but I
can shout for help in 1990s grey worm
yeah he knows jokes but he reminds us
he's a soldier who doesn't Lee have time
for levity and then there's Tyrians joke
about the Lannister the Martell on the
start motto flux the fly out and
swallows it home the stock reaches into
his cup pulls out the fly and shouts
spit it out your wheeze [ __ ]
spit it out so first off this is another
bit that's ripped off from our real
world except it's usually an Englishman
and Irishman and a Scot I'll hit but the
point of the joke is that the Lannisters
are spoiled and overly classy the
Martel's are impulsive and they don't
give a flying one thinks of them and the
Starks are dumb and obsessed with honour
both because they think that they could
talk to a fly and that the honorable
thing to do would be to have the fly
returned the Ale that I drank man isn't
it a lot of fun to explain jokes that
sucks
but anyway the point is the head Tyrians
joke reminds us that he has no respect
for that entire system of houses ruling
in Westeros however it also reminds us
that he's still very fascinated by the
houses and their reputation which makes
sense because he's a famous product of
one of the most prominent houses also
the other joke that Tran tries to tell
once walked into a brothel with a
honeycomb and a jackass it's actually a
callback to the same joke Tyrion tried
to tell way back in season 1 I once
brought a jackass and the honey code
into a brothel he doesn't get to finish
it then either though adorable little
freakazoid Robin is desperate to know
how it ends
honestly I wouldn't be surprised at the
whole series ends with Tyrion telling
this joke and considering it has to do
with brothels and honeycombs and donkeys
I would also not be surprised as a
punchline has something to do with a
sweet ass that's my guess now before we
move on I just want to point out
something about grey worm even though he
wants to be the soldier that has no time
for comedy he cracks that smile
even last this right here this is the
entirety of graveworms character art in
one moment he was raised as a killing
machine never meant to feel or connect
with anyone and here he's laughing
alongside a woman that he's probably
developed feelings for he's taking a
moment to live a vibrant colorful life
rather than this pale existence of a
grey worm and that's why I hate to say
this but I think grey worm is gonna die
I know that it's kind of out of nowhere
but whenever I feel like we see a
character art complete this happens all
the time I'm walking dead I feel like
that's it for that here like I gotta say
if I'm right I am gonna miss the guy I
didn't think I would but I've grown
weirdly like attached to that little
unit hopefully I'm wrong but let's start
heading into the final scenes of the
episode we go back to Riverrun and we
get this very interesting scene with
Jamie and Ed Muir so you remember that
this episode is all about choosing your
identity are you no one or are you
someone and if you are someone who is
this someone you choose to be so note
how both bran and Ed Muir talk about
Jamie's good looks and specifically his
face
that's another connection to the acting
we talked about earlier and how actors
wear faces which is why poor little
Bianca could never begin hector's again
and like how all faceless men act as
other people they wear literal faces
while they do it
Jamie wears the face of a handsome man
the knight in shining armour type he
looks like Prince Charming
but the reason ed Muir is totally
fascinated by this is because according
to him Jamie is the opposite of that
he's a disgusting vile creature it's
kind of like the portrait of Dorian Gray
by Oscar Wilde it's a story about a man
who stays young and handsome while he
secretly is keeping his soul inside of a
portrait of himself it grows older and
more hideous to illustrate how corrupt
the man has become inside but here's the
thing about Jamie
he knows this about himself he knows it
better than anyone else
so he actually in this moment does
something very subtle he pretends to be
Jamie the villain in order to be Jamie
be honorable a lot of people said after
this episode Oh Jamie's back to being
like he was in season 1 or 2 I don't
agree I think he's putting on the face
of that Jamie but he's faking it he's
acting Jamie threatens every Tulley and
has that crazy line which is from the
books by the way about position filled a
people
and I'm launching into Riverrun with the
catapult and to even further underline
how much Jamie is playing the old
villainous part even quotes himself from
the pilot things we do for love things I
do for love
in reality old villain is Jamie wouldn't
have only made this threat he would have
killed men to make his point he probably
would have already sent to the baby he'd
probably be torturing EDD mir-2 instead
he makes a calculated move to step up to
Briony challenge if he plays his cards
right yeah his reputation is probably
gonna take another hit but it's already
garbage and if he can take the castle
without any bloodshed he'll prove
breanne right and maybe he does have
some honoring him still it's a lot like
his killing with a Mad King something
that looked terrible and something Ned
Stark always judged him for but
something that was actually done for an
honourable reason and his threats are
again based on Tully words note that
like Santa's letter he specifically
hammers home the point about Ed Mears
family is baby and all the Tully family
he has will be killed he threatens him
with that rather than threaten ed mere
any more personally and it works and
this manipulating based on the Tully
words actually keeps working because
when the Tully men take ed Mears orders
even though they all obviously know it's
a trap they are honoring the second word
of their house duty they don't have the
option of not listening to him they must
obey it is their duty and so as we then
move on to the blackfish and Brienne
trying to convince him to come with her
if we finally get what part of the Tully
words drives him he showed last episode
when he said that they could kill ed
mere and he wouldn't care that family no
longer drives her which makes sense that
later when Bryan asked him to do right
by his blood aka family he declines a
surprise when you complete you a beat
and we know he doesn't feel any sense of
duty to Ed mirror as he feels like he's
probably the guy that should be calling
the shots not him so it's the third
Tully word that drives him now honor he
wants to maintain his honor and he wants
to salvage it actually it was really
quick but he reminds us he ran away from
the red wedding and he feels a lot of
shame over it that's why he wants to go
down this way
in a battle protecting his home it
doesn't matter that he's already lost it
to him is a way to regain his honour
Brienne refers to it as pride and she's
probably right honestly the blackfish is
being stubbornly proud but that is who
he is what's funny is that the reason
he's called the blackfish is because he
was the outcast of that house and he and
Kaitlyn's dad the former Lord Tully
hated each other because the blackfish
thought that he was too stubborn father
was a stubborn old ox so it seems like
they were actually probably just too
similar here's a fun side note by the
way the very next scene in that episode
I was just showing where Brendan talks
about accountants dad that's Rob's wife
Tulisa caring for a Lannister boy does
he look familiar he looks like Tom and
right except nope Cara Lannister auntie
Martin understa
so not only was Tommen played by a
different actor a few seasons back but
the actor that plays Tommen now he was
already on the show playing a different
Lannister I think that's so ridiculous
but also I'm impressed that I didn't
notice for a long time anyway I already
mentioned that despite the major
tactical victory when Jaime finds out
that there was bloodshed and one of his
heroes has died he knows he failed to
live up to Brienne's goal for him though
I'm sure she'd actually felt understand
she saw how stubborn he was being but
Jamie doesn't understand so from his
perspective he thinks that he probably
just is the bad guy whose face he was
wearing during that scene with that
mirror so him waving goodbye to Brian is
also him waving goodbye to the Honorable
version of Jaime that could be with her
yet at the same time there's hope
because just like how Vader saves Luke
Jaime letting Brienne and pod go that
shows they're still good in him I think
the whole point of this Riverrun story
was to show Jaime this other side to him
exist and while he clearly thinks that
he can't have it or he doesn't deserve
it
he's definitely gotten a taste of it now
and considering what we think Cersei is
probably planning back home I would not
be surprised if he does get back there
and suddenly there's trouble in paradise
for that couple okay and who else is
hoping that Brienne and pod are just
gonna bump into Gendry on his rowboat
path but just me I want to know what
happened to him that's all so after
Danny returns to marine for a split
second how we see the Hound finally
catch up with the original Brotherhood
without banners and the familiar faces
of Thoreau's of Mirim beric Dondarrion I
told you last time that if we saw berrak
it meant that we probably were not gonna
get the crazy other new leader of the
Brotherhood that would be amazing so
just go ahead and tell you that would
have been Lady Stoneheart and if you
don't want to be spoiled just don't
Google and
about who that is and editors let's not
show too clear of a picture here but
basically she's terrifying but super
interesting and since barrack is still
there
we're probably never gonna get her on
the show and actually it was really
obvious that the show runners knew that
we were wondering about this because
they dropped hints to the character all
of the so long if you know her story you
heard the hints they were dropping and
in the books the person is pulled out of
the river right by where this
Brotherhood is so when we saw the river
and it kind of looks like a last chance
for Lady Stoneheart to appear instead
the show gave us this true enough that
seems like a pretty clear yeah no we're
not gonna do that story anyway too quick
others may point out here when the Hound
steals lends boots before he's even done
dying one in the books limb actually
stole the hounds helmet so this is a
reversal of that but to the Hound is
actually acting out an exact part of
brother Ray's broken man speech if they
want new boots they need to take him
from a corpse even though the Hound is
exactly the guy brother ray thought he
was the broken man it's not until barek
tries to recruit the Hound that it
actually all starts to click for him and
you can see a potential path to
redemption here that makes sense because
one brother ray believed violence wasn't
necessary and unfortunately in this
world as the Hound knows and now for a
nose that doesn't work but to the hound
actually believes that beric knows
something about coming back because he
actually saw the guy do it and it blew
his freakin mind and it all touches on
our theme - about choosing your identity
as Jamie chose to play the role of the
Kingslayer and in a moment Arya will
choose to stop playing roles and embrace
the person that is our historic the
Hound he's choosing to go in the middle
he's not exactly the Hound anymore he's
showing restraint he's not killing all
these guys the time I would have killed
all seven of you just a gully street but
he hasn't found some amazing new persona
he wants to embrace so instead he joins
up with a group who literally has no
banners meaning they belong to no one so
they're all no one and the Hound is
choosing to go with that for the time
being and it's funny because like I said
last episode he and Arya just keep
having these inverse stories from each
other now I should say like what this
scene was setting up because one I'm
really excited to see these guys march
north actually it's gonna be an
interesting
addition to have them also want to
battle against the White Walkers but on
another thing I like tears sander
talking about his interest in chicken
enjoy you sure so chicken it's a nice
callback to the time that he killed a
bunch of guys cuz he wanted to eat some
chicken bring me one of those chickens
you got money not a penny think I'll
take two chickens you don't seem to
understand the situation any more words
come pouring out your mouth I'm gonna
have to eat everything chicken in this
room okay and finally the episode ends
where we started back in Braavos we get
this chase scene and the director
admitted that he watched some very
famous chase scenes to inspire him here
and while he didn't say which ones I
think it's pretty clear that he borrowed
a lot from Terminator 2 with the waste
running style and her eerily calm
performance there was also some
inspiration from the Bourne Identity and
it's famous shaky-cam chases note though
that when we are feeling the waves
perspective it's pretty calm and steady
and then when were in Arya's world it's
more of the shaky camp style she just
has a lot less control over what she's
doing right now
but another famous film reference that
the director made actually admits he did
it by accident he didn't intend to at
the time but he totally agrees that it
makes sense and then maybe he was
subconsciously doing it these oranges
ever since The Godfather or just have
famously been used by filmmakers as a
way to signal a death that's about to
happen the director says that he
actually did want to make that exact
moment right there the moment that the
chase goes from a rapid run to a slow
march toward what feels like arias
impending death so he made an accidental
perfect film reference to set that up I
guess happy coincidence but also this is
where the mr. Eicke starts to begin
because when arias sees the blood she
realizes she's bleeding again but she
also gets her idea to purposely leave a
trail for the way to follow back to her
hideout and as we predicted she uses a
benefit of darkness to take out that
annoying annoying girl I hope she just
like pulled her face off I hope that's
how she killed her and this takes
historic closing images and I feel like
I already kind of explained what they
mean it's the second half of arias
earlier rejection of being an actor was
already then choosing to step away from
being no.1 but in this moment she
finishes it by choosing who she will be
instead a girl is Arya Stark of
Winterfell it's nicely matched with the
opening images of the parallel character
of the actress playing a role for then
choosing to go off-book and taking off
her mask
to reveal her true self but instead of
just wrapping up here I'm actually then
point out a few other interesting things
I noticed first as of this moment Arya
John Sansa and brand
they've all been freed from their
obligations they've all returned to
being stark children and have decided to
all start heading back to home to
reclaim what is their speed Winterfell
for their identity or their little
brother or their mission so Arya saying
I'm coming home the nice connection to
Sansa and John realizing that there's
only one place for them to go to live a
week oh there's only one place we can go
home but this is actually illustrative
visually to by purposely mirroring the
exact same framing for when Jon Snow
quit his job and eventually decided to
reimburse his stark heritage and another
quick thing one of the faces on the wall
it's Bill Simmons he's the guy who
created the ringer which is the company
that is behind after the Thrones that
show on HBO he's also the guy in all of
those bill simmons HBO commercials
uh-huh but anyway more interesting than
that I want to point out I'll go ahead
and call it a theory but I think we're
too late in the video for another theory
time I want you to pay attention to what
we're shown in these final moments
jockin comes into the main room of the
house of black and white and he sees
large puddles of blood tracking across
the floor we did just see arya bleeding
a lot
realizing she's probably reopened her
stab wounds and we saw REM lots of pain
moments ago confirming that she's
definitely still injured but jockin and
the camera follows these puddles forward
to the pool and this is the same pool
that is known to be poisoned and kills
those who drink from it then jockin goes
down some steps into another area and he
finds the blood dripping again though
note that these jobs are definitely much
smaller than they were over by the
entrance they lead to the wave space up
on the wall now again it this might not
be anything at all actually but I want
to acknowledge the possibility that
would actually happen here was that Arya
came back to this place with the wave
space and she purposely took a big swig
of water from this pool because if you
remember even though the pool poisoned
some for some reason it's magic healed
Arya's blindness a few episodes ago and
so yeah if she's guessing correctly then
it would have healed her wounds and
stopped her from bleeding and then that
remaining blood that we see is just the
lesser drips of the wave space as Arya
walks it to the wall and this would
explain why after we saw her
moments earlier having just torn open
her wounds hunched over pain or is now
walking through this scene like she's
got 12 hours of sleep and like
Deadpool's healing abilities she seems
great so I'm not gonna put my money on
this theory being true but they
definitely did focus on that pool for a
long time so maybe nothing maybe
something let me know what you think
about that in the comments but also some
questions here followed by well I'll
give you more details about the giveaway
in a second a 1 there's a good chance
that Aria is going to pick up her list
again when she gets to Westeros who do
you think she's gonna kill first if
she's fast enough she can take out
Walder Frey while he's still relevant to
the story but also beric and Thoros are
also on their way and lucky for them
they just reappeared so where do you
think she's gonna head and who do you
think she's gonna kill to if you know
the Lady Stoneheart stuff do you think
it'll ever happen or is it just
definitely dead no pun intended
also cleganebowl it got squashed by the
no trial by combat rule but is that
still gonna happen first I actually feel
like yeah I think so but probably not
this season but I've been saying that
for a while so we'll see 3 I brought
this up earlier but what do you think
Varys is up to like I told you my Dorn
theory but do you think he's going on
some other secret mission also do you
think his timing to leave his suspicious
or weird it kind of feels like he's
avoiding tener should come back she has
to
okay now the giveaway stuff first off
thank you again to loot crate for
helping us to do all of this I'm
actually gonna go ahead and open my mate
here while I tell you about this stuff I
haven't seen this yet actually but I'm
super excited I've also got a level up
crate to check out which is nerd clothes
um sometimes you guys ask me where I get
my nerdy shirts and that's often where I
get them from it's also from Luke Ray
when I dropped it okay well I'm very
pumped for next month's dystopia theme
because for some reason I'm really into
the aftermath of like apocalyptic stuff
all-out and Mad Max when we're not I
just love when the world gets destroyed
remember that if you want the dystopia
stuff which is June you would have to
sign up before the 19th by 9 p.m. our
sign up link should be on the screen
right now it's loot crate that
constructs rockstars and make sure to
use our rockstars code so you get the
10% off whoo let stands out right away
boom
since what I'm talking about they just
send you like legit figurines and stuff
but it's not always just figuring this
is a metal diecast version of the Iron
Man Mach 5 suit lights up
to who
got all the like Civil War ones - this
is so much bigger than every other puffy
ger I have he can just rain over them
all that said he didn't exactly win
Civil Wars so I don't know ha how
perfectly well time because who did win
Civil War your big fan of cap wear caps
this is a Captain America hat it's a
loot crate exclusive actually I actually
don't like hats not never been into hats
I'm kidding I love that but if you I
butcher - oh this giveaway is something
special that loot crate and I actually
came up with for my Twitter followers
luckily if you don't follow me on
Twitter it's very easy to do and totally
free actually uh so if you sign up for a
subscription of loot crate you just try
out the June box all you have to do is
tweet at me telling me who you think is
going to win Game of Thrones like the
entire thing and maybe why they're going
to win you only have so many characters
to choose from and also only so many
characters to write with on Twitter so
get creative with your word choice oh
yeah send me those tweets and then we'll
pick a winner at random and then the
winner you're gonna be getting obviously
your loot crate stuff that you just
signed up for but we got you you're like
a freak rate of level up which is just
nerd clothes I'm gonna rip this open
really quick so that's one of the things
is more that you'll get if you win a
Mario Brothers scarf another shirt oh
that's pretty cool
master the universe key man style
another long-sleeve shirt Oh precious
with so many S's uh yeah Lord of the
Rings Tolkien guys like if you like like
Game of Thrones probably would like Lord
of the Rings
that's what george RR martin is trying
to do he loves Tolkien and he's actually
trying to improve on his works but I
mean this is like the og who boom Super
Mario hilarious socks which I will wear
right now boom now my feet are warm oh
yeah so the winner will be picked at
random and in addition to your lucrative
subs you'll be getting a free crate of
level lava so it's a bunch of nerd
apparel just like cool free clothes but
also you're gonna get the Game of
Thrones magnets that I use for weekly
power ranking I'm just gonna send you
those directly or stead of mine and then
I'm also gonna send you my personal
Stark direwolf USB flash drive my own
one and it's not gonna be empty I'm
gonna put all kinds of really
interesting things in there related to
Game of Thrones and some theories that I
also don't want to state publicly but I
do have
about Game of Thrones I don't want to go
into too much detail about what I'm
gonna put on here because I want to ruin
the surprise but it's gonna be awesome
stuff on that flash drive that one
interesting thing I will tell you about
is that we're gonna make you your own
custom video featuring me Eric our
director Kyle Oh answering just whatever
question you want or explaining any
concept of theories directly to you for
you probably about Game of Thrones but
you can ask us about something else you
might not know anything about it but
we'll make that video just for you and
it'll also come on that flash drive ok
so that's a lot of stuff that you can
get and I know a lot of contests are
like oh I'll never win that there's
gonna be way too many entries trust me
they're not gonna be too many entries
for this I would love it if there were
because it would make everybody happy
especially lootcrate but yeah
realistically your odds are gonna be
crazy good that you're the person I
would get all that stuff again all you
have to do is sign up for a badass nerd
stuff from loot crate I tweet at me that
you did that and who you think is gonna
win Game of Thrones and why and that's
it we'll talk to the winner via direct
message on Twitter that simple ok so
that's it for this episode breakdown and
hope you were happy that we got it to
you a little bit earlier that's directly
thanks to loot crate for helping us do
that to keep up with us in general
follow out new rock stars on Twitter
follow me at fimo if you want to talk
nerd stuff or if you have longer stuff
to say you can always hit me up on
facebook at facebook.com slash fimo
knows you guys are the best
I'll see you oh my god for the epic
amazing episode that's coming I'm so
excited but thank you guys for
everything bye